hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll and today's
episode I think it's safe to say is one
that has been anticipated for quite a
while by a lot of people out there in
mindscape land now usually I'm an ornery
guy and if a bunch of people demand that
I do this or that I sort of resist doing
this or that for exactly that reason but
in this case the wisdom of the crowd was
absolutely on the right track so we're
very happy to have Lennie Susskind on
the podcast to those of you who are
physics fans Lennie is very well known
for his technical work for his popular
work for his semi technical books the
theoretical minimum and within the
physics community extremely well known
as a storyteller a mentor and a guiding
visionary of the field for those of you
who don't know him you're good you're in
for a treat both the personality that
comes through very clearly and also the
subjects that we're going to talk about
Lennie was one of the founding fathers
of string theory he has done an enormous
amount of work in quantum field theory
and the standard model but today at the
age of 78 he is leading the charge to
understand the black hole information
loss paradox this is the thing that
Stephen Hawking bequeathed to us in the
1970s when he realized that black holes
give off radiation and if you throw
information into a black hole how does
that information come back out in the
info in the radiation or even does it
come out so let me like I said is one of
the leaders in tackling this problem
which is probably the single biggest
clue that we have to ultimately
constructing a theory of quantum gravity
so this has led people into things like
the 80s CFT correspondence it from qubit
a whole bunch of very mind stretchy
ideas so we're gonna do our best in this
podcast to bring those mind stretching
ideas down to earth to make them
understandable and to convey some of the
excitement that physicists like Lenny
and I because we work in very very
similar fields really feel these days
about the progress that's being made in
the prospects for what's going to come
very very soon so buckle up this is
going to be quite a ride and I think
you're gonna like let's go
[Music]
léni SATs good welcome the mindscape
podcast all right how are you so what
one question I'd like to ask of people
who are identified as string theorists
is are you a string theorist do you call
yourself that
I really don't I really don't I had a
lot to do with it in the beginning and
then more recently but I like to just
think of myself as a theoretical
physicist
I think it's smarter because then you
can do whatever you want right yeah you
do what you're curious about one time I
was curious about that the other times I
was clear accused about other things and
I tend to follow where my where my nose
leads right just so we can get it on the
record do you have a feeling for the
present state and possible future of
string theory as a field yes I think I
do
um I can't tell and I don't know if it's
gonna be the let's call it the theory of
everything I hate that term but I'll use
it anyway people get it ah whether it's
going to describe in any of its given
forms whether it's going to describe
nature as we know it but I can tell you
what it has done it's provided some very
very concrete very very precise and we
call them examples of theories models
however you want to call them are they
contain gravity that contain
electrodynamics that contain particles
that contain fermions and bosons the
various kinds of particles that we have
in nature and looks a lot like what we
think nature looks like at least when we
look in the laboratory we see particles
we see gravity we see all these things
and they're there and so what this
provides us with is a highly precise
mathematical situation where we can try
out ideas and one of the ideas that was
most important in all of this was the
consistency of having quantum mechanics
and gravity in the same mathematical
theory and I think by virtue of string
theory and it's spin-offs I think we
know with certainty now that
mathematically quantum mechanics
we can fit together sensibly and
consistently that is no small thing and
it might not be our world that we live
in but it that's right it might not be
but we now know the two can fit together
that this idea that there was some
breakdown where quantum mechanics and
gravity simply could not fit together I
think we're quite sure that that is
wrong and one of the great sort of guide
stars we have in this game is the
entropy and evaporation of black holes
right and you wrote a wonderful book
that I'll plug the black hole world war
written many wonderful books but that
was a great one many well okay a few
I've lived a couple so I have to say
they're wonderful Oh
and so what what do we learn I mean
let's imagine that the audience has
heard the fact that black holes
evaporate but don't know many details
yeah and we take it many of us take it
that there is some quantum mechanical
lesson here and and in particular
there's information from which the black
hole is made and we're not sure where it
goes so how do you think about this
puzzle this sort of legacy that Stephen
Hawking left us right
okay so Stephen asked a wonderful
question it was a deep question it was a
profound question let's not mix it up
with a question of whether he answered
it correctly sometimes questions can be
more important and leave a bigger legacy
than the attempted answers and I think
that's probably the case and Stephens
legacy that his question is almost
dominating the areas of physics that
I've been interested in for the last
twenty thirty years completely
dominating him Stephen simply asked a
very simple question he said if
something falls into a black hole and
the black hole evaporates well by almost
by definition something that falls into
the black hole cannot get out of the
black hole and so what happened to the
information that fell into the black
hole now we can get into all kinds of
questions of what we mean by information
and so forth but just basically the
ability that in principle looking at the
looking at what comes out of the black
Cole is it possible to reconstruct or
fell in in principle given technologies
which is way way way way beyond anything
we're likely to ever have but assume
that we have it then it's physically
possible
can one reconstruct were fell into the
black hole and there was a tension there
the tension had to do with the fact that
in basic quantum mechanics nothing is
ever lost in the sense that if you know
the quantum state afterwards you can
reconstruct what the quantum state was
before that's a principle of quantum
mechanics and so in that sense nothing
can ever get lost on the other hand
black holes were places where things get
lost when anything falls past the
horizon of a black hole we were brought
up to learn that they cannot get out
they trapped there there forever and so
there was a tension there do they I
don't they get out can you reconstruct
to put it in practice what it meant was
when a black hole evaporates it has
evaporation products anything that that
rates leaves products coming out there's
a black hole the products of evaporation
of a black hole in principle can you
reassemble them and figure out what fell
into a black hole as simple as that
Stephen said no I'm a bassist that black
holes are places where you can have
escape from and other people myself
included said nope you have to be able
to because basic quantum mechanics says
you have to be able to who won I would
say quantum mechanics so I want to bring
up a yo there's a funny little paper by
a philosopher Tim maudlin I don't know
if you were no argument but he makes the
following point that our notion of time
is a little bit subtle in general
relativity and in particular we could
imagine calling the universe both the
outside of the black hole and the inside
of the black hole simultaneously in
other words the universe is disconnected
into the interior of the black hole in
the exterior the black hole and then you
could imagine that time just plugs on
and information is not lost
in the whole quantum wave function it's
just hidden forever in the black hole
like it's a baby universe is that a
possible resolution that you'd be
sympathetic to know why not black hole
evaporates it's gone it's gone in some
slicing of the universe and sometimes in
practice in the laboratory the black
hole is gone yeah there's nothing left
but not even a little remnant that tells
you there was a black hole there
all that's left is the outgoing Hawking
radiation principles of quantum
mechanics said that that radiation has
to carry the the information now can you
wiggle and can you find ways to try to
from in vague against that no doubt you
can but I think by now your first
question had to do about string theory
and I told you that string theory
provides us an extremely precise tool
and which we can investigate these
questions in a mathematical context that
we have a lot of confidence in the
answer that comes out of that highly
mathematical but precise context is
nothing has ever lost a black hole so I
think so I think this is this is a solid
conclusion as I said it's not a small
thing and even even even steven
even-steven been cheated by what you
think he did stick to his guns he did
stick those he's a stubborn guy but he
would change his mind once it became he
did indeed absolutely clear so one way
that this is often put is if you throw a
book into a black hole the laws of
physics quantum mechanics and say that
in principle you should be able to
measure all of the radiation that comes
out to reconstruct the book yeah I mean
measuring is loaded term in quantum
mechanics you have to be careful but
there was a sin sandwich it's in there
anyway well you can measure it or not
but it's the information is there so
let's just sort of go through some of
these thought experiments this is after
all the thought experiment just so the
audience knows we haven't made any black
holes and watch them evaporate right oh
no we have not
so is it possible that somehow when the
book falls into the black hole its
information is duplicated into the
outgoing radiation and we get it that
way well that's an interesting question
can one model one picture of what
happens is as information falls into a
black hole it's exactly as you said it
gets duplicated Xerox let's call it 1
copy falls into the black hole so people
who fall into the black hole with the
information see it smoothly pass through
the horizon and the other copy is
radiated back out with a Hawking
radiation and then you have what do we
have our cake and eat it yeah we do
we're having our cake and eat it too
that's ok this is an OK theory I think
the problem with it is it's known in
quantum mechanics that you cannot really
duplicate information that quantum
information true quantum information
cannot be duplicated I thought I
discovered this fact and I called the no
quantum Xerox principle it had been
discovered before by by quantum
theorists that's called the no-cloning
theorem it's one of the most central
properties of quantum mechanics that you
cannot faithfully reproduce the quantum
state and you can't duplicate it as you
said so that left us with a funny
situation you can't even at least within
the usual rules of quantum mechanics
save the situation by duplicating the
information on the other hand what if
you could duplicate the information but
nobody could ever in principle detect
the fact that you've duplicated into the
information now it's a little stale
better shows we care what people can
detect yeah physics is an empirical
science and you start getting very I
know I get very troubled when we put
mathematical things into a theory that
in principle can
be detected ozone I'm not saying you
should never do that I'm not saying that
under no circumstances should be things
in a theory which are what's called not
empirically it's confirmable but you
should be a little bit nervous about it
if you discover that because of the laws
of physics that you already trust that
you you even if you did let's say
duplicate information it would be the
outcome would always be that you would
get frustrated in trying to confirm that
you did something bad
I'll give you an example in a moment
yeah okay you might start to worry that
you're thinking wrong so here's the
example Heisenberg taught us a long time
ago that you can't know both the
position and the momentum of the
position and the velocity of a particle
and so you line up I can't you do both a
particle is just a little thing if it if
it has a position then it can have a
position at two different times if it
has a position at two different times
then it moved from one place to another
how can you not know the velocity at the
same time is a good point yeah that's a
good point and yet it turned out that in
quantum mechanics that no matter how
hard you tried to be able to measure
both the position and the velocity doing
one would always frustrate the other and
so we came to understand that really
there is a conflict the tension or
whatever you want to call it between
knowing the position and the velocity of
a particle and that you simply can't do
both
you simply can't do both so best then
that your theory not allow it in
principle or better yet that the theory
never allow an experiment which goes in
quantum mechanics doesn't say a particle
can't have a position and a velocity it
says nobody can ever detect both of them
yeah okay I you know as I never ready in
I would say there's no such thing as the
position or the velocity there's only
the wave you can say it any way you like
I'll take the view
quantum mechanics doesn't say any such
comprehensive things that a particle
can't have a position in the velocity
what it says is that any experiment to
design one will always frustrate the
other so you ask with a thing falling
into a black hole and so forth does it
get duplicated it doesn't get duplicated
supposing you discover that using the
rules of quantum mechanics and gravity
you will inevitably discover that any
attempt to witness the duplication was
always get frustrated if you measure
what's outside you can't measure what's
inside if you measure what's inside you
can't measure what's outside very much
like position and velocity then maybe
you'll say it's a principle similar to
the uncertainty principle that you
simply can't do both and that's my
feeling about it now so the the thing
that would have been imaginable is we're
imagining some literal observer sitting
outside the black hole collecting some
radiation from it yeah and then diving
in really quickly and reading the book
inside well apparently not apparently
not it always turns out again you always
get frustrated if you wait long enough
on the outside to be able to collect
this information in the Hawking
radiation you'll always find out that by
the time you jump in the first copy of
it the first clone of it has fallen into
the singularity and it's gone you can
never get there right and this is you
know this is not a lightweight statement
this is based on calculation and
geometry and so forth you find out that
an attempt to learn both or fell in and
what came out at the same time gets
frustrated it takes too long to learn
what came out so that when you jump in
what went in is gone into the
singularity and likewise of course if
you just jumped in you could read the
book but then you can never go out again
right so yeah so you get access to one
copy of the book you'll never to - yeah
that's what yeah and so what does this
tell us about how we should think about
black holes in quantum mechanics
well we should think about black holes
and quantum mechanics in a way which is
probably not too different than we think
about quantum mechanics that that you
cannot know everything quantum
mechanically which classical physics
tells you that you can know classical
physics tells you you can know the
position and momentum of a particle at
the same time it tells you that you know
can know the phase and the energy of an
electromagnetic wave or if you don't
want to know what that means it means
something you can't know both or at
least classical physics says you can
know both quantum mechanics you have to
be consistent you have to be very
consistent use quantum mechanics as it
was designed to be used and be very
skeptical when you're when you um when
your rules when your principles seem to
how shall I say to lead you to some
contradiction or something yeah well
certainly when I lead you to a
contradiction then you should be
appalled to go back to the drawing board
but when you're using concepts which in
principle by virtue of the of the rules
of the game cannot be confirmed yeah
okay so but this does have this sounds
may be to the people out there like this
is an esoteric topic dealing with
recovering information from black holes
which would be impractical anyway but no
there seem to be very deep consequences
for the nature of space and time itself
like usually we think of information
being located somewhere and this is
saying we shouldn't always ask that
question yeah there are there's not a
good question to ask where is the
information it may be a good question to
ask when a particular way of gathering
that information with a particular
protocol for detecting that information
where is it that it will be found but
more generally different ways of
gathering information may detect me may
come to the conclusion
one way would say was here another way
would say it was there without any
contradiction because nobody can do both
is there any worry that this way of
talking gives so much emphasis to
observers that we're being a little bit
anthropocentric or something like that
that we're putting agency back into
physics that expression that wagon has
already left the stable horses are
enslaved large by the phone 1926 that
was quite a character but are you I mean
we're allowed to get on slight tangents
here when it comes to quantum mechanics
are you a many-worlds person or do you
are you agnostic about foundations of QM
yeah I think I think agnosticism I just
got my old friend Richard Fineman this
subject is so confusing I can't even
tell if there's a problem he was asked
exactly the same question yeah what do
you make out of the foundations of
quantum mechanics and so forth and his
answer was it is so confusing that I
can't tell if there's a problem and I I
feel that way
quantum mechanics always works I expect
it will always work I expect nobody will
ever do an experiment that will violate
it on the other hand there are some very
very deep and hard I don't even know
that they're hard questions to answer
maybe unanswerable about the
relationship between let's call it
reality and the mathematical symbols
that we use on a piece of paper yeah and
I share I share both findings skepticism
of whether there's a problem there and I
share whoever its feelings at birth that
you should be able to describe quantum
mechanics without collapsing the
wavefunction etc etc so one thing I do
think is I don't think we will come to
the end of the story until we do
understand that the relation between
gravity and quantum mechanics okay
that's interesting yeah yeah I just it's
a sense that I have that too much in
quantum mechanics and too much in
gravity seem to influence each other and
connect to each other in surprising ways
that until we understand that connection
perhaps it and also connecting with with
cosmology horizons all these things that
maybe until we understand those things
better it's a little bit premature to
have a final set of answers about
quantum mechanics but I don't know yeah
my guess is it's not gonna happen in my
lifetime I don't know I'm optimistic I'm
working on it mr. come 78 work it hard
okay so just to get back to where
although I can see you're no I I know
but I'm working hard you seem very very
healthy so we have the situation where
we want quantum mechanics to be true and
we know some things about black holes
and so this leads us to this relatively
profound suggestion that information
doesn't have a unique location in space
and is this is this basically what you
have dubbed black hole compliment yes
yes very much so
complementarity in the same sense nobody
could ever figure out what Bohr was
talking about it so directly but to
distend an extent that we do understand
what Bohr was talking about is
complementarity pretty much in the same
sense that information about position
and information about momentum are
complimentary
you can't have both you can have one but
not the other and it depends on what
experiment you do so I was trying to use
the term in the same way Bohr used it
and you were lucky enough that Bohr was
unclear about how he was using it and
that's closely related to another
feature of black holes evaporating that
you've also played a major role in which
is the holographic principle
why are we so holography somehow asks us
to think of the entire black hole as
either being or living on or being
encoded on the surface the area around
the black holes so why in the world
would anybody think something that crazy
well okay the the reason is the bounds
on how much information can be stored in
a region of space and as I'm sure you
know there's a deep set of arguments
that begin
with bekenstein hawking hoofed myself
and so forth which concluded
mathematically that the amount of
information that can be stored in a
region of space can not be larger than
the surface area of the region but
that's unusual because normally in most
physics you would imagine the amount of
information number bits that can be
stored in a region of space would be
proportional to the volume of the region
yeah that's normal physics I mean I'm
just putting a bit at every location in
space what's harder that's right put a
bit of every bit of information of every
point of space and then your number of
bits will be proportional to the volume
indeed what's so hard about that well
what's so hard about that is you wind up
putting so much energy into the region
of space that you create a black hole
and the black hole will be bigger than
the region that you were trying to
populate in the first place with
information so using ideas from black
holes from Hawking from bekenstein and
so forth I think it tough tonight both
came somewhat independently to the
conclusion that you under no
circumstances could you ever put more
information into a region of space then
its area area measured in little
plunking pixels and once you say that
you begin to think well maybe this
should be some theory in which the
interior volume of a region should be
described by degrees of freedom that
live on the boundary can you explain a
degree of freedom in yeah it's a bit of
information if infinitely a bit of
information you know and I won't try to
describe what a bit is zero and one zero
one yeah
quantum mechanical version of that the
quantum mechanical version of zero and
one right that there should be if it's
absolutely impossible that under any
circumstances you can ever contain more
than an area's worth of information
again perhaps that means there should be
a description of it
in terms of a theory which lives on the
boundary that was called the holographic
principle when when the Tufts first said
it nobody understood at all there was a
reason no no there was a reason he wrote
a paper that I didn't even know about
and it was called dimensional reduction
in gravity yeah what he meant was that
the dimension goes from three dimensions
the volume to the surface area the word
dimensional reduction had an entirely
different meaning for most physicists
entirely did don't worry about what it
meant it meant something entirely
different and since I was not in any way
interested in dimensional reduction at
that time I'd never even looked at I
didn't even know about it well this is a
lesson for young people out there you
can be you know one of the world's most
famous physicists but if the names the
titles of your papers or not that
enticing people are not gonna read them
yeah I think that's true and I felt he
was thinking a little bit different than
I was but nevertheless we came to the
same conclusion that the maximum amount
of information you could put in a volume
was a surface area and therefore there
should be a theory of that type where
everything is described by a surface set
of degrees of freedom we call it the
hologram I think he even used the word
hologram somewheres in his paper I
actually put it in the title and because
a real hologram is a two-dimensional
hologram is a piece of film that's
two-dimensional if you look at it
through a microscope all you see is a
bunch of random little dots and they're
you know just nothing you can make any
sense out of but in in codes full
three-dimensional information so we go
we both independently called it that I
can tell you when the idea first came
out nobody noticed it was a tuft at all
they did notice when I wrote it okay why
I think I was clearer I think I was
clearer
I thought it was a very famous physicist
and Nobel Prize winner yet one of my
real heroes yes
right so nobody noticed that they
noticed it when I wrote it
and I think a lot of people said you
know those two guys used to be good
physicists but they lost their marbles
one of the few people who really did get
excited about it was Ed Witten he from
the beginning caught on to the idea and
Henry Lane yeah yeah written also to
those of you who don't know like one of
the most respected physicists yes
definitely but the one who really made
it precise and made it reputable let's
say not only reputable turned it from a
wild speculation to a almost clear-cut
consequence of quantum mechanics and
gravity and eventually to a tool when a
speculation goes from speculation to a
principle and then eventually becomes a
tool of the subject then you know that's
that's yeah and by the it we're talking
about this it's all about it all of this
three-dimensional reality can be encoded
that was one maldacena yeah one now the
same there is now one of the very great
physicists in the world and he he again
he did not know about our work Edward
did written did maldacena actually did
not he came to with his own strange way
from actually from string theory but the
result was the same and he had a very
very precise mathematical version of it
it's the one that we call a DSC of T now
that's from string theory and it was so
mathematically precise and you know so
convincing that it became as I said a
principle and then a tool of physics you
know I think this is sufficiently
important and central that we should
explain a DSC of T there's six letters
there is two things
ATS and CF t so ad s is a
kind of space-time it's not the
space-time that we live in a geometry a
geometry of space-time and why is it
called a DS that stands for anti the
sitter
now the sitter was a physicist
mathematician physicist from the early
parts of the 20th century who discovered
a kind of space called de sitter space I
used to joke that his aunt discovered
into the service de sitter was
classified actually as an astronomer
yeah yeah he was an astronomer Yeah
right he was a little solved Einstein's
equation formed and found the space
called the sitter space which is
incidentally thought to be the space of
the kind of space we really live in yeah
we're getting it right but we understand
that much less than we understand into
the civil space now auntie de sitter
space is in some sense the opposite of
the Sudanese it's not really the
opposite it has certain opposite
properties one of them is positive
positive curvature the other one has
negative curvature it's not like a
particle and antiparticle if you brought
them together they disappear it's just
in some sense anti-de sitter space has
opposite properties to the sitter space
it turned out that was the one that was
most amenable to mathematical analysis I
think I'll just interject one little
extra piece of information the sitters
face is characterized by having a
positive amount of energy in empty space
a positive amount of dark energy right
maybe you didn't want to use that term
vacuum energy whatever but the space
itself and anti-de sitter space is the
kind that has a negative dark energy
vacuum energy suffusing all of space and
that's the only thing in the universe
there's no particles there's no galaxies
there's no dark matter just vacuum
energy everywhere if it's a positive
number be de sitter a negative number
which sounds crazy and it's certainly
not what we have in the world but the
space you get is anti decision right and
for reasons which a technical string
theory was very very comfortable with
auntie de sitter space and extremely to
this day uncomfortable with the sitter
space
yes an ongoing thing like how to
reconcile the observed fashion that
vacuum energy is possible with what
string theory says should be the case
right but now the saying that simply
took started with string theory
constructed out of the rules of string
theory this anti-de sitter space and
analyzed it and realized that it had
this property that we call the
holographic principle he didn't even
know the term and his paper doesn't even
refer to it ed Witten who was closely
related to the string theory the centers
of string theory did write it wrote a
similar paper and called it a lot of
holography Nate I disagree base in a lot
of things right so he was but he was
very familiar with my work and work so
the reason Juan did not mention it was
not because Juan has trouble mentioning
other people's work no no so so you had
based on black holes this speculation
that somehow the information was encoded
on the boundary of the black hole
maldacena has an example of a specific
space-time anti-de sitter space where
everything that happens in that
space-time is somehow encoded on a
boundary with one lower dimension oh no
in my work and in the Tufts the black
hole is just a starting point the
eventual conclusion is that a region of
space no matter what's in it black hole
and no black hole will be described by
such a boundary theory right but we had
absolutely no idea how to build that
kind of theory and you know it was it
really was a speculation yeah I wouldn't
say a wild speculation because I
understood the reasons that we were
pushed to it but it did sound pretty
pretty out there
while the sane is version of essentially
the same thing was highly mathematically
precise and analyzable you know with
theorem proof proof proof equations
equations real equations you don't get
to speculate as much because there's
equations that cover I think I think the
number of
equations that appeared in the tough
paper in my paper all together the
number of relevant equations both papers
had a lot of equations both most of them
were irrelevant the number of equations
was very small and Malta say in his
paper if I'm if I remember correctly is
now the most highly cited paper so I'm
torretta kinetics right so this is
important so good so so malta saying
that says look here's at least an
example yeah we have one theory but
there's two different ways of talking
about it in these two different ways
seem utterly different one is there's no
gravity and it's a quantum field theory
and the other is there is gravity but
there's an extra dimension is one higher
dimension of space yes what have we
learned from this weird construction
well what do we ever learn what do we
learn and we learn we with ok I'll tell
you what I think among other things like
many more things gravity does not seem
to be a thing that you quantize I'll
tell you what I mean by that
ordinary theories like quantum
electrodynamics or the theory of a
harmonic oscillator or the hydrogen atom
the quantum mechanics of those theories
was constructed by a recipe it was a
recipe that was invented by Paul Dirac
and it starts with a classical theory
and then you apply some rules to the
classical theory called quantization and
you produce a quantum theory of it that
never worked for gravity it was the fact
that it never worked the matter how hard
you try you always ran into infinities
or information being lost or something
really bad went wrong it was that that
made people think that there was this
tension between quantum mechanics and
gravity and that there was a conflict
between them I think it's turning out
the other way I think the point is that
they are so closely connected so almost
the same thing that the idea of
quantizing one of them
it separates them too much it separates
them too much from the beginning to save
is this classical theory and this Quan
and quantum mechanics and we put them
together they're just too closely
related so you're saying in other words
that other theories you can start
classically and then construct this
quantum theory but right the right way
to think about quantum gravity is just
to be quantum from the start yes and
more than that I think almost all
quantum systems have features in them
which are reminiscent of gravitational
things even though they may have very
little to do with so we can find echoes
of
also echoes of that's right of curved
space-time in ordinary simple quantum
mechanical systems malva saying this
construction was an example of this he's
roughly speaking he said if you could
construct a sphere of material a sphere
of material a shell where the shell have
a certain properties that would allow it
to be described by certain kinds of
quantum mechanical field theories and
shells of matter I'll describe by
quantum field theory that we can do yeah
if we could construct just the right
kind than in every possible way and in
the laboratory in the laboratory nothing
out of space is we could construct this
shell and we could communicate with it
by tapping on it listening to what it
does and so forth that for all possible
purposes we would discover that what was
going on inside contained gravity even
though if we opened up the shell we will
find nothing in it very weird I mean it
closes this to doable oh I think it's
getting there we're not gonna build such
shells that would not be the right thing
to do we will build quantum hopefully we
will build quantum computers that can
quantum simulate those shells right
quantum simulating means that the actual
quantum mechanics that's going on in the
quantum computer is a direct reflection
of the same
quantum mechanics that went on the shell
or in Malthus anus constructions will
have these quantum computers we will be
able to interact with them by perturb
you know by by have you we interact with
computers
let me not explain how we interact with
computers we interact with them we make
measurements on them we look at a screen
whatever what will be going on inside
those computers will be pretty much the
same as what goes on in a black hole in
a quantum mechanical system that
contains gravity so I think I do believe
in the end we will be able to do a
certain class of experiments with
quantum computers whose results if we
took them literally would say you know
what's going on inside here gravity
black holes all sorts of things even
though if we opened up the common
computer all we will find will be
circuits and so what's the end point
here what the end point is it may turn
out that quantum gravity a great theory
of gravity great theory of quantum
mechanics but it might eventually turn
into a tool for quantum computation
science I think it's already going in
that direction it's it's already very
much going in that direction that so by
that we mean like building a better
algorithm for a quantum computer better
algorithms but the one thing that
especially comes to mind is building
better error corrected error correction
error correction is a big deal in
quantum computation let's let's just
back up a bit because I think this is
very valuable what's so great what is a
quantum computer and what makes it so
great why is it better than a classical
computer it's because quantum quantum
mechanics of a given number of qubits
was it was B or a bit as a thing as a
switch which is either on or off a
quantum bit which is called a qubit it's
a quantum mechanical version of that but
it has more it has it's a richer thing
than a single bit that can be in a
superposition of states not up now and
I'm not up not down but up
Plus down and so forth so quantum bid is
a more complicated thing now quantum
bits a collection of quantum bits has an
enormous capacity for what I call
complexity much more so than the
corresponding classical so the amount of
information that you would necessarily
have to provide that describe the
quantum state of a hundred qubits is
vast it's huge but that also means that
that hundred qubits can store an amount
of information and that could be just
vastly bigger a qubit could be encoded
and you know an electron that if they're
spinning clockwise or counter clockwise
so a hundred electrons doesn't sound too
hard to hang together and rolled into a
machine four hundred four hundred
electrons the amount of information that
it would take to describe the state of
four hundred electrons is as big as the
maximum amount of information that could
ever be put into our entire observable
universe if it was attacked as tight as
possible I think thank right so four
hundred what's four hundred four hundred
is you know this is nothing
four hundred qubits in principle can
store that much information the question
is can you get out of the computer and
this is you have to be very very lucky
to design an algorithm when not only can
you store and answer questions involving
that much information but also be able
to get it out of the computer
so people are doing it right now for a
couple of qubits at a time right now in
very simplified situation arts but if we
could make it dozens or hundreds then a
world opens up a world opens up and
we're not exactly clear we're really not
exactly clear what that world is we know
that there are a hint there are a
handful of problems that we know that
are much too hard for classical
computers the buzzword is that they're
exponentially hard problems which are
exponentially hard which cannot be
solved by any reasonable classical
computer
that quantum computers can solve when
the quantum computers are built
there's also another class of problems
which are very interesting which are
simulating physical systems quantum
mechanical physical systems we build
into the quantum computer a set of rules
which is analogous to the rules which
let's say govern a superconductor and
then we can examine in the computer what
happens when you do this when you do
that you have a lot of control things it
would be too hard to actually do to the
superconductor itself so you get to
explore changes what happens if you
change the computer the the
superconductor a little bit this way a
little bit that way this is one of the
Richard Feynman's of a gel notation
earring absolutely yeah absolutely
so that's a world that may open and
there will probably be a wider class of
problems of quantum computers can solve
but the problem with quantum computers
is because they have so much capacity
for complexity they're also very
delicate little tiny errors that
wouldn't have any significance at all
for a classical bit a classical bit is
like a coin which is either heads or
tails you put your coin on the table and
you sneeze what happens nothing nothing
this is a pretty robust head stays heads
it's not susceptible to error because
you because you sneezed you sneeze on a
quantum a bit in oh boy you've entangled
it now it's all tangled it you made a
mess out of it okay so that means that
you have to be extra special in your
protection against errors errors are
random flips of bits random errors that
classical bits are not terribly
susceptible to and quantum bits are very
susceptible to so that means you have to
build in redundancy you have to build in
to your quantum computer redundancy and
error correction what's called error
correction so that if it happens that an
error is made the computer by itself
detects the area and
exit okay one of the really interesting
things has happened is that possibly one
of the most interesting theoretical
constructions about error correction
that's happened in the last X years has
come out of thinking about black holes
remarkable fact there's a dialogue going
on a very robust dialogue going on
between this kind of gravitational
holographic community called the it from
qubit community it from qubit yeah it's
from Cuba communities John Wheeler
suggested it from bit that the reality
emerged out of information yeah you
saying well he was almost right it's
quantum it for me
right that's the best of gravity people
that's the Malthus anus of the world
witness it's thing I'm involved in and
so forth and at the same time the
serious hardcore quantum computer
community which is technological they're
building things yeah they're Hardware
building things right building things
with technological purposes in mind and
the two communities are beginning not
only beginning there for the West I
think probably for about four or five
years five years now I think there's
been a very strong interaction between
those two communities with lessons
learned from gravity or quantum gravity
being transported into into the computer
science and lessons learned from the
computer science transported I'll give
you an example yeah we have these things
in quantum gravity called wormholes that
connect that connect black holes that
can connect black holes if they're
entangled the right way okay I'm sure
our listeners have seen science-fiction
movies yeah interstellar yeah okay
is it possible to send information into
one black hole and have it come out the
other we always thought the answer was
no that that would violate some basic
principles until a few of us started
thinking about a phenomenon that the
quantum computer and the quantum
community
Haitian community its called quantum
teleportation quantum teleportation is a
way of using entangled systems to send
messages which are entirely secure and
which seem to go from one place to
another without passing through the
space in between we now know that that's
the same phenomenon as as putting a
thing into one black hole and having it
appear through the wormhole coming out
the other one okay but just so that the
people who are not experts are grounded
here quantum teleportation we can see in
the lab that you can do it can't you
don't see there you know you don't see
the information it's a real down there
oh yeah quantum teleportation as it
sounds little way out but it is an
absolutely real thing it has it's hard
to do it's not easy to do but it has
been done and it will be done more and
it's considered a technology for you
know ultra secure communication but
nothing actually disappears and then
reappears right it's a information that
is teleported not like a dog
ya know it's information it's teleported
but you put something in one end and it
comes and an equivalent thing comes out
at the other end right right that's
called quantum teleportation it's a real
thing and we now know that sending
things through wormholes is this exact
same mathematical phenomenon you can't
use it to send things faster than the
speed of light that doesn't have still
true yeah it's still true and you can't
use it to make flying machines oh that's
right oh yeah yeah but you can use it
for ultra secure communication which
can't be detected by an eavesdropper
okay principle can't be and so you're
giving me the impression this is not
just a bunch of enthusiastic theoretical
physicists saying cool things that they
think quantum computer people should
care about you're saying you didn't want
computer people actually do care about
yeah and there's a lot of crosstalk
there's a lot of crosstalk look I
actually wrote a paper with it
did we actually write the paper together
we did the work together game with a
with a computer scientist
I'm Scott Aaronson oh yeah let's go
let's go Aronson future lines get
podcast guest here's write better yeah
that is something that if you would have
told me 10 years ago I would write a
paper with a computer scientist I would
have said oh you're crazy I have no
interest in that but more than much more
than that I wrote a paper with him we
talk a lot not just Scott and myself but
Derrida Hana of you know a whole world
who was devoted to the technology of
quantum computation has now come
together intellectually into an
intellectual community which consists of
these gravity quantum mechanics people
the quantum information people the
quantum computation quantum
communication and these are real
technologists and if yeah so I have two
questions I don't want to create either
one the first one let me put myself in
the sort of skeptical position here and
and wonder about how abstract this all
sounds like here we are we're in a room
there's chairs there's tables and you're
saying that secretly it's all a
two-dimensional screen of information
yeah is that like how secure established
robust is that or is this a bit of a
cost our fingers hope it's true kind of
thing again I'll say again the
importance of string theory to this
community and to this set of questions
it is it has provided very very exact
precise examples in which these things
are true does that mean that they're
true of the real world not necessarily
not necessarily not necessarily but it's
possible that it is possible is but it
sort of says look this the mathematics
of this is very very secure there's no
question that this can happen so it's
definitely a useful tool right don't
place where it happened yes it's
definitely a useful tool for a number of
things but the place where it happens is
with with precision is in these anti-de
sitter spaces what do we know about the
world we really live in
the sitter space it's auntie the citizen
fu space right and we don't know with
the same confidence we certainly don't
know with the same confidence that that
the rules for ant they deserve it the
rules for the sitter space are the same
we don't so is it possible that at the
end of the day all this work ends up
being really really useful for people at
Google who are designing algorithms for
quantum computers but doesn't help us
understand the nature of space-time or
you want to tell your friends there that
we're sitting in the office for people
out there in podcast land we're actually
doing this interview in an office at
Google X right why why because I consult
for some reason Google X thinks that
theoretical physicists are really
important to senior consultants so
that's evidence for everything you can
say right right
but our computer scientists useful for
theoretical physicists like Adi do you
see the theory of everything
emerging from the clouds here well I
don't know about the theories for
everything I've learned a new way to
think in my old age I'm not very good at
it the computer science way of thinking
about things but a lot of what I think
about these days was ideas that were
born out of computer science the most
important way of which is called
complexity theory which turned out to
have a direct application in the
interiors of black holes okay complexity
in what sense how does the computer
scientist think about complexity complex
the complexity you can think of a
complexity of a thing or you can think
of a complexity of a process but of
course a thing is also a process a thing
is a process the process of making it
from something simple yet there another
how do you assemble something yeah the
death the definition of computational
complexity is the number of minimal
simple steps that it takes to go from A
to B so if you're let's talk about I'll
give you some examples of complexity my
favorite was always when I was young I
was interested in theorems I don't prove
theorems anymore right but it was
interested in for someone else to do I
was very curious about the fact that
some theorems are hard and some theorems
are easy what's the difference I mean
they read the truer their false whether
what's this hard
easy what does it mean my teacher my
high school teacher told me that the
four colormap theorem is thought to be
very very hard and so hard it see the
troll it's not true how do you go have
you make sense that this idea of hard
and easy and I didn't know then I later
learned out that there were theorems
that were so hard that they were true
but they were so hard that they couldn't
be proved period was the girdles
invention and I got very curious what
does it mean to say that a theorem is
harder than another theorem it turns out
what it means is that it's more complex
what is more complex mean that the
minimal number of steps to be able to
prove it not the number of steps that
some mathematician might have used but
the absolute minimal number of steps
logical operations starting with the
postulates and using logical operations
and or and so forth then that that the
complexity of a theorem is what the
minimal number of steps to prove that
theorem is and it's a hard number given
a theorem you can say what the what the
complexity of it is hard theorems are
more complex than easy theorems and this
is a profound statement because a hard
complex theorem in this sense might be
very simple to state yes indeed the
four-color from is very simple to state
but very hard to prove so that's a
different notion and the proofs of it
involve you know books worth of
equations one after another plus a
computer computation okay yeah so the
number of minimal steps to prove the for
colormap theorem is thought to be very
large compared to proving X square plus
y squared equals Z square what's that
called Pythagoras yeah and and somehow
this illuminates what's going on in the
interior black holes and ok so in
quantum and quantum computation you can
see supposing I want to do a certain
calculation what's the minimum number of
basic unit quantum steps that it would
take my quantum computer to carry out
the calculation minimum not the number
that you design you you may have used a
lousy algorithm gods number right what's
the absolute minimum and that's called
the complexity of the calculation
a black hole evolving is carrying out a
calculation what does it mean it just
means that it's running it's evolving
it's evolving on a bias that's why a lot
of information is evolving and one of
the very exciting things that for me was
to discover that the computational
complexity of the evolution of the black
hole had a direct meaning in terms of
the volume of the interior of the black
hole that was very exciting to me why
I've always loved the ideas of
complexity theory I never thought they
would come into physics I've been
fascinated by black holes have been
especially interested in their interiors
and to suddenly discover that the growth
of the interior of a black hole is a
case of growing kind of computational
complexity was very exciting is it
having it is again part of this dialogue
between the computer scientists and the
physicists doing these kind of
gravitational black hole kind of things
and yeah I expect that that will have
some impact yeah okay this is all like
cutting-edge new stocks very taken out
yet and having these two communities you
know some some great thought may come
out some great consequence may come out
of this interaction and it may be
impossible for anybody to ever really
figure out exactly what the route to the
the great thought was was it what he
said was she said was it what the
computer scientist said was it getting
communities like this together in a
situation where they really do have
common interest and common enough common
tools to be able to honestly interact
i I think has been just very very
exciting and it's part of the thrill of
theoretical physics right that we attack
problems from different angles and when
they come together we know something
smells right yeah that's right and the
other thing which makes you think you're
on the right track is when something
that you've been thinking about turns
out the same mathematics or the same set
of principle
turn up in some other area and turn out
to be useful in that other area you know
really really good stuff usually
penetrates into several different
directions many directions not just the
directions that it was intended for and
when that happens you know that there's
something good about what about what
you're doing so that is happening it's
also entering into what's called
condensed matter physics condensed
matter physics is the physics of
materials some parts of condensed matter
physics are now very heavily using the
mathematics of black holes why black
holes are kind of material their
horizons of the horizons do things they
have viscosity they have electrical
conductivity the horizon of a black hole
wobbles it does stuff and it turn it
again it's turned out that the
mathematics of the surface of black
holes turns out to be very similar to
the mathematics of fluids the
mathematics superconductors mathematics
of other things and that mathematics is
being transformed back and forth between
the two communities so one of the
biggest and hottest items in the
gravitational subject is something
called the syk model okay the syk model
was first invented by a condensed matter
physicist by the name of such
associative yes yes that's s and kitaev
Oh who's the KE
is also as a computer a quantum computer
scientist an account a colleague they
invented this model or at least such
they've invented this model to describe
a certain class of materials which are
called whether they called lousy
conductors yeah not superconductors
right no not super but the opposite
right and he invented this model for
that purpose it turned out that today
I've looked at it who is not a
gravitational person at all and realized
from a little-bitty that he knew about
black holes is that this model was
describing something like a black hole
and now all the black hole physicists
this is the hottest sight of now that's
why k-theory I mean it helps to be as
brilliant as Alexa q Talia just yes sir
but think about it was a material
science guy a condensed matter physicist
and a quantum computer guy who found the
opening and I think it's a serious
opening for new ideas about black holes
that is that it's a it's a wonderful
it's a wonderful synergy going on the
interesting question how long will it
last
these these kind of ideas and these kind
of synergies that happen they have a
finite lifetime they don't last forever
I think this one has probably at least a
good 10 or 15 years left in it good
advice for the young people out there
division please okay it will be part of
the textbook subject yeah of course the
subject will move on into other things
and this one will be the domain of older
yep let me let me bring it back to sort
of wrap things up here but let's bring
it back to where we started in string
theory because there's another obvious
set of questions about gravity and
space-time which or the cosmological
questions or your universe and so forth
and you alluded you alluded you know
Kaija lead to the idea that we should
take seriously things that we can't even
in principle observe if they're
predicted by our theories one example of
that is the cosmological multiverse
which seems to be part of the string
theory story do you still think that's
true I think so I even wrote a book
about it yeah the cosmic landscape will
plug that book um yeah you know I let me
put it this way I don't think anybody
has a better idea for resolving some of
the great puzzles of cosmology the great
theoretical puzzles of cosmology in
particular the very very strange or to
call fine tunings that we see that we
seem to see in nature that parameters
are extremely finely adjusted and we
don't know why there's of course a lot
of almost anger at this idea of a
multiverse and so forth we both felt it
yes my answer is always yeah what do you
that's better and the answers never
anybody has anything better so it's the
best idea we have right now for
understanding why the parameters of
nature are what they are we don't have a
better idea and that's about all I would
say about it with real conviction could
it turn out to be wrong I suppose so but
I don't see how but to say that I think
it could turn out to be wrong is to say
that I see some other possibility and so
I'll just be clear to it in this case is
the idea that there are regions of space
very far away where local laws of
physics look different that's the
multi-verse or things right so let's
have packaged the idea that the universe
is extreme some parts of it we know with
certainty we know the universe is much
bigger than the part we can see how
could we know that it's much bigger than
the part we can see the same way that we
know that the earth is much bigger than
the portion that I can personally see
right
we know it's much bigger not because
we've been around the world but because
we see it's very flat if we go out in a
field we see it's very flat we know that
probably going on for a long distance
because it's so flat it probably doesn't
terminate at the place where we see the
horizon that would be weird yeah and the
universe at the same universe is the
same way it's very flat it just seems to
go on and on and there's no reason to
think it stops at what the horizon is so
how much bigger at least a thousand
times bigger in volume so that means
it's a potential for lots of stuff out
there that might be somewhat
unrecognizable to us more likely it's
millions and billions and billions and
billions and billions of times bigger so
to say that the only things that are
possible the only kinds of environments
the only kind of behaviors that are
possible are the kind that we see in our
little tiny patch well it's presumptuous
it's entirely possible that the universe
is full of different kinds of patches
with different kinds of behaviors just
like the earth is full of different
kinds of patches artic jungle desert
that that there could be a great deal
going on out there and
so there may be very many different
environments on only a small part of
which habitable which are the parts that
there have inhabited the parks that are
inhabited the parts that I habitable
yeah what does it take to be habitable
well possibly some very special numbers
numbers for the fundamental the cons of
fundamental Condor right so it's not
that everywhere in the whole universe is
all the same and that we could live
anywhere at least according to this idea
they're just a small tiny fraction of
the universe which is of the type that
is habitable but where are we we're in
the place which is habitable yes as dumb
as that it doesn't take a heavy
philosoph philosopher to understand this
concept and string theory helps us by
sort of allowing right for all there's
many many different solutions the
solution means a possible kind of world
yeah with different parameters with
different numbers and so you take these
things the fact that we know the
universe is much bigger than it is then
maybe then we can see the fact that the
parameters seem to be highly fine-tuned
and the fact that string theory gives
for rise to an enormous diversity of
different possibilities those are the
three things that go into this idea is
it is it a is it a open-and-shut game in
other words is it done as the fat lady
son yet no I don't think so but my usual
answer to the critics of it is you've
got anything better buddy and the answer
is almost always no it seems to me and
maybe I think it back
the answer is always and always no so
far anyway yes yeah these wonderful
ideas we've been discussing about qubits
and quantum information and the
emergence of space-time it seems to me
that they haven't yet attempted to
address mostly cosmological questions
what happens at the big is this an open
area you think that's had a lot I think
it's an open area
[Music]
I won't try to predict what the next
area will be that will be exciting
because I usually gonna be wrong
something will come up that getting an
expect but you know just in the natural
course of events if science and the
physics is going to answer these
questions it's got to address that
question how does how do these ideas
bits qubits strings and all that kind of
mathematics holographic principle a DSC
of T or something different
how will they address the cosmological
questions and I think that's unknown
like it's unknown although there are
plenty of people have some ideas and the
ideas may be good I think they certainly
haven't reached consensus okay and so
for my really final question then in
addition to helping to reinvent the
nature of space and time and to spending
time here at Google X with the quantum
computing folks you've also written
several books right not only
straightforwardly popular books but the
theoretical minimum yes series and
there's video lectures I mean how how
what is the way that you think about
your activities in that realm like how
important is that to you
that's an interesting question I did it
I did it for two reasons one of them was
a sort of emotional response to my
father of all things my father was a
very smart man he was a plumber
he had a fifth-grade education he had a
bunch of friends they were all plumbers
rough characters but they were all
intellectuals this was you know a long
time ago and we was part of New York was
it the Bronx the Bronx okay
they'd sit around the table I would say
was a little kid that would sit around
with him they'd talk about everything
they would talk about history they would
talk about science all kinds of stuff
and it was a very strange mix of
intellectualism and crackpot ISM why
crackpot ISM it wasn't that they were
intrinsically crack Bobby when I
particular when it came to science it
was that they had no access to be able
to know what was real from what
a bit of crackpot saying yes and when I
when I started to get really interested
in science I started to try to teach my
father
it worked things but I always had this
emotional sense that there were all
these guys like my father out there I
would like to be able to teach them
what's real sciences so they know the
difference the people I met when I got
older that that reminded me of a little
bit or they were they were actually
scientifically pretty literate people a
lot of the older people that I met in
the community in in Palo Alto these were
people from everything from from
computer programmers to doctors things
like that and they were very very
interested in science they were very
interested in physics and generally
older and at some point I decided to try
to teach and Stanford's continuing
studies program the idea was to teach
one quarter and to give them sort of
Scientific American background into some
of the modern physics they loved it it
was extremely popular the one quarter
and so when to a second quarter and then
a third quarter but it was intended to
be at the level of let's call it
Scientific American they came to me at
some point and they said enough with the
Scientific American stuff
he just physics socially all things show
us the equations to do it right and so I
did I think I spent 10 or 12 13 years I
don't know how long
over and over teaching courses to these
people they weren't courses in the sense
that anybody took an exam they were just
you know me lecturing and the teacher
that the fun part good old fun part and
at some point they decided to take the
lecture notes and write them up into
books so that was the origin of the
theoretical minimum
are we done is there another volume
coming out there will be some time okay
very good
well I completely agree I think he right
I think is the norm
audience if we do it well to explain
science at a pretty good level yeah yeah
I think it's important to explain an
honest level and honest level allows you
to use things like metaphors and
analogies but you must you must explain
what is a metaphor what is an analogy
and you must also explain why it's
deficient because they almost always are
yeah so all right well you've done a
fantastic job about it I hope the
podcast helps sell you some books let
neat us can thank so much with you in
the podcast okay
[Music]